[Music]
should I just do it regular speed no
just a slightly less slightly left
slightly less than just for safety sake
right like I want to get worked up a
little bit alright yeah yeah and then
you come in yeah and touch me like
alright here we go
alright I'm okay did I screw that up but
sorry I'm gonna try that again I'm sorry
that's no good I messed up I'm sorry go
fat yeah you know my problem was I
couldn't see I was looking there and I
couldn't see where you are I'll touch
your back and then yeah and I'm there
and I'll do it slightly slower than that
so I'm gonna do this you're gonna come
in and how long should aunty should we
get bring Indian a little after that so
I can talk a little more like in-between
like I'm enjoying it so you're a nice
you're such a nice surprise yeah yeah
did I really hit you no no okay good I
did fart a little I think and she